but we have to you can forward it's okay i can't just listen okay listen as you can see your
pattern is eight minute but you can forward you can so out of 10 is your what is your one
as you can see it's split up into two parts you have a can i like that one any mistakes that you
make or if it's a minor mistake a minus 0.1 if it's a major mistake you get minus 0.3 so i'll
just let you guys know about the difference between two so when i'm saying it's a very
very small thing so let's say it's not close let's say there's 20 steps and you may even see
attention as you can see it's from a score of six uh this six is actually split up into three parts
so we have one two three so we'll start with the power and speed so with this through the slow
fast slow you're a little bit nervous so that's why i'm 1.1 so this is your average so say you
did uh you did all right you did average compared to everyone else your score for one two and three
it'll start from 1.1 so if your was above average you might get small uh down to this like so with
this one uh as i was saying it's a total
of our 10. so let's see so for presentation it's usually at the panel and each one obviously
the first objective so uh from their point of view you might have made a lot of mistakes or you may
i mean okay not a lot of mistakes it's also a few things mistakes very small mistakes so if they're
all uh minus 0.1 you'd be 1.5 so you go 4.0 minus 1.5 which equals so if you're a color dot if you're
a yellow or above and you do your patterns it's not uncommon generally for a color belt uh the
average is about pretty good so do you want us
this is actually
gonna score yourself so question do you want us to do the minor music every single step or every
poem because every single because just tell me what you're like right now yeah because the rule
is like per poem yeah that you you do the minus okay oh i see whatever you feel like would
capture the performance okay yeah i got you so if i'm done watching it i just close it close it close
and then continue continue um so this is what it looks like oh but usually we need to watch it and
do it yeah so you're going to be watching it and then doing it so this is minor errors okay real
time we cannot pause this time and then major errors yeah no problem and you're going to be
watching it and then after power and speed yeah yeah oh nice okay so your scores will be calculated
at the end when you're ready
so
so so
Thank you.